[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24 12e
jour de guerre en ukraine la population
civile de plus en plus victimes du feu
russe les bombardements se sont
intensifiés dans les villes ukrainiennes
haïr pin à kharkiv la deuxième ville du
pays ou encore à marioupol où les forces
russes poursuivent le siège de ce grand
port du sud est de l'ukraine l'armée
russe tentent d'encercler kiev où les
sirènes d'alert aérienne ont retenti à
l'aube plus d'un million 700 mille
réfugiés ont fui l'ukraine en dix jours
selon l'onu il pourrait être 5 millions
à vouloir quitter le pays pour échapper
à la guerre moscou a annoncé la mise en
place de couloirs humanitaires mais qui
oblige la population ukrainienne à se
diriger vers les territoires occupés par
les forces russes ces couloirs sont donc
rejetées par les ukrainiens et la france
dément qu'il ait été créé à la demande
des modèles macron le chef de la
diplomatie américaine quant à lui
anthony blinken a jugé très crédible des
informations qui font état de crimes de
guerre commis par l'armée russe on va
s'intéresser donc dans cette émission en
particulier au sort de la population
piégée en ce douzième jour de guerre
pourquoi finalement les russes se pose
pospisil des couloirs humanitaires vers
la russie ou la biélorussie vladimir
poutine devra-t-il rendre des comptes
alors que le chef de diplomatie
américaine évoque des crimes de guerre
on en débat avec mes invités j'ai
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés julien
theron bonsoir enseignant à sciences po
paris spécialiste des conflits des
relations internationales hauteur de
poutine à la stratégie du désordre co
écrit avec isabelle mandraud du monde
c'est chez tallandier bienvenue dans le
débat avec new line à vau-l'eau chine
elena bonsoir notre correspondante en
russie correspond donc de france 24 nous
aurons également avec nous frédéric joly
bonsoir porte parole du cicr en france
merci de participer au débat et
bienvenue à vous
également gulliver craag est avec nous
notre correspondant donc en ukraine
correspondant france 24 bonsoir gulliver
bienvenue également dans le débat avant
de démarrer cette discussion je vous
propose d'écouter quelques réactions
d'ukrainiens ans ce douzième jour de
guerre
et chaque wii tue des gens sans raison
tout cela est tellement dur pour la
population
c'est de la folie je préfère être ici à
kiev parce que si la situation se
dégrade
je pourrais aider je suis infirmière
donc s'il y a des blessés j'aurai
forcément une utilité l'univers craque
donc va nous rejoindre un petit problème
technique avec lui la vie va où il est
en ce moment on va tout de suite aller à
kiev justement retrouver andré qui
habite kiev qui à 39 ans bonsoir à vous
l'armée russe donc tentent d'encercler
la capitale vous êtes resté à kiev
contrairement au reste de votre famille
vous voulez rester quoi qu'il arrive
pourquoi
bonjour tout le monde moi je peux faire
lille n'a pas en plus j'ai déposé mon
dossier dans la défense territoriale ici
à quai malgré que je n'ai pas généré
aucun expérience militaire dit
expérience de combat
jusqu'à la quatrième que je sais moi
donc j'ai pris la décision ou rose pour
défendre il était aux défendeurs de je
peux faire la logistique que je peux
aider aux hôpital quatre ans j'ai fait
la logistique ou territoriale en
revanche votre famille a quitté kiev a
quitté l'ukraine
ma famille a quitté qui n est pas
quitter le crème minceur avec sa famille
de petite fille est là dans la partie de
l'ouest de l'ukraine et mes parents ils
sont à la campagne à 150 kilomètres ils
ont quitté qu'il va retrouver tout de
suite du l'hiver craquer nous a rejoints
gulliver notre correspondant à kiev qui
est donc en ce moment elles vivent de
l'hiver bonsoir on vous voit cette fois
vous êtes donc en ce moment cette ville
de l'ouest de l'ukraine qui est un petit
peu une ville comment dire une ville où
on se replie où il ya l'ambassadeur de
france par exemple qui s'est replié quel
est justement l'atmosphère vous avez vu
d'ailleurs un certain nombre
d'ukrainiens qui souhaitent fuir
l'ukraine
oui il ya les missions diplomatiques il
ya les médias il ya certaines
entreprises qui se sont repliés ici mais
il y assure tous les déplacés les gens
qui ont fui d'autres endroits de
l'ukraine et qui cherche un endroit où
dormir et qui se demandent s'il faut
rester ici ou aller ailleurs qu'ils
cherchent quel est le meilleur projet
pour pour continuer ou pour reconstruire
la vie est ce qu'il faut considérer que
le départ et définitive ou est-ce qu'il
faut considérer que c'est seulement
temporaire tellement de questions que
les gens ici se pose qui ont qui ont fui
les endroits où ils habitent
officiellement ils sont vingt-cinq mille
mais on pense que en réalité le chiffre
est bien plus élevé que cela le chiffre
de vingt cinq mille cinq cent vingt cinq
mille enregistrés en ce moment mais le
processus d'enregistrement des personnes
déplacées prend un certain temps parce
que il y a des délais administratifs du
seulement à la au volume de personnes
qui demandent les autorités essaient de
mettre en place un système où tout le
monde doit être enregistrée notamment
aussi parce que il y a beaucoup de peur
dans cette ville aussi deux agents
russes qui pourraient être ici qui
pourrait agir et donc même parfois les
déplacés sont vus avec une certaine
suspicion même s'ils sont aussi bien sûr
accueillis par toutes sortes
d'associations il y a vraiment un très
grand réseau de volontaires qui s'est
mise en place pour les aider frédéric
joly de la croix rouge vous êtes
également avec nous la croix-rouge
ukrainienne a doublé ses effectifs
depuis le début de l'invasion en
recrutant trois mille volontaires et
elle a averti que l'urgence humanitaire
en ukraine provoqué justement par
l'invasion de l'armée russe allait créer
des déplacements des besoins massifs à
ce que cette guerre vous en rappelle
d'autres comment ça se passe pour la
croix rouge sur place
ce qui singularise ce qui se passe
depuis 12 jours en ukraine et c'est la
problématique des guerres en ville des
zones densément peuplées avec des
combats utilisant des moyens de guerre
extrêmement lourd et qui font que
finalement c'est la population civile
qui devient l'enjeu presque du conflit
avec des gens qui n'ont pour choix que
de se terrés dans les caves des
immeubles ou alors de partir de fuir
donc on réussit votre votre confrère le
disais à l'instant ont réussi à
s'échapper mais se retrouve des places
et manquant de tout est dépendant de la
générosité et la solidarité par exemple
de familles hôtes de centres
d'hébergement dans d'autres endroits
mais pour ceux qui restent terrés les
piéger dans le combat en ville la
situation est alarmante et ne fait que
s'aggraver de jour en jour puisque les
conséquences humanitaires font que par
exemple à marioupol il y à de grandes
difficultés maintenant à trouver des
vivres à trouver de l'eau et bien
évidemment à de plus avoir accès aux
soins donc l'urgence est toujours là
elle risque de s'aggraver si
effectivement dans les négociations et
bien l'agenda strictement humanitaire
n'est pas mieux pris en compte pour que
les populations civiles soient le moins
impactées dans les jours et les semaines
qui viennent julien theron c'est très
difficile d'en avoir des chiffres sur
les victimes du conflit en douze jours
de guerre d'après ce que j'ai lu il ya
des centaines de civils qui ont été tués
des milliers peut-être d'autres blessés
est ce que vous avez des chiffres au
mois d ordre de grandeur non c'est très
difficile dans des villes qui sont
assiégés notamment pour avoir le compte
et puis parfois il est difficile même de
retrouver les corps donc dans les
décombres des immeubles donc c'est très
difficile et en plus vous notez bien que
dans une perte d'exode il certaines
personnes on compte donc c'est
effectivement
compliqué mais je rejoins ce que disait
le représentant du cicr parce que dans
les études sur les conflits
effectivement la population aujourd'hui
est un enjeu majeur c'est un enjeu
majeur à la fois politique on l'avait vu
déjà l'euro maidana la population était
motrices politiquement et aujourd'hui
c'est aussi un enjeu majeur parce que
s'ils voulaient cette population qui
fait complètement corps avec son état et
son personnel politique eh bien elle est
punie elle est punie de sa résistance et
de ses orientations pro-européenne ena
volochine alors vous étiez à moscou il
ya encore tout récemment à la frontière
même de l'ukraine côté russe moscou a
proposé des couloirs humanitaires mais
qui oblige la population ukrainienne à
se diriger vers les territoires occupés
par les forces russes donc soit en
russie soit en biélorussie les
ukrainiens donc s'y opposer banel macron
dément d'ailleurs être à l'origine de
cette idée on va écouter président
français je vous fait réagir juste après
les couleurs humanitaire selon claire
c'est la possibilité de faire sortir ces
femmes et ces hommes la russie plaide
pour faire des couloirs humanitaires
vers la russie
je connais pas beaucoup d'ukrainiens qui
est envie d'aller se réfugier en russie
c'est une hypocrisie et donc je sais est
un artefact de communication que je
réprouve c'est une hypocrisie c'est du
cynisme dit emmanuel macron lna oui
alors il faut comprendre que pour
vladimir poutine cette guerre elle va
être compliqué d'un point de vue de
l'opinion c'est à dire que s'il peut
l'emporter militairement et clairement
sa belle et ite et celle de régner sur
l'ukraine il va avoir beaucoup plus de
mal avec ces populations qui ont vécu de
ce côté-ci de la ligne de front à
instaurer à avoir une adhésion et
finalement à mettre ces populations-là
de son côté pourquoi parce que depuis
2014 et l'annexion de la crimée et cette
guerre dans le combat ce qui l'a
provoquée sans le dire il a galvanisé
les populations de cette partie du crâne
de laisse donc ces républiques
populaires autoproclamé dit de donetsk
et de lougansk y sont pas passés côté
pro russe à force de propagande qui le
marque killer martelait que les nazis
ukrainien veut l'aîné les attaquer et
ces populations-là donc elles ont été
finalement convaincu à la cause de
moscou à force de propagande et à force
de cette création cette ligne de front
côté ouest et donc de ce côté ci de la
ligne de la ligne de front côté pro
européen en fait de l'ukraine les
habitants ont été de plus en plus
farouchement opposé à moscou au fur et à
mesure qu'avançait cette guerre et qu'il
considérait cette occupation de l'est de
l'ukraine par la russie et donc on va
avoir la des déplacés qui fuient les
combats mais aussi beaucoup de réfugiés
de l'opinion qui est forcément fuient
vers l'ouest est-ce que moscou essaye de
faire là c'est en fait de convaincre par
une opération qu'elle appelle de
maintien de la paix 1 que lé là pour
porter refuge à la population alors
qu'en fait elle en train de les attaquer
poxel l'instrumentalise en fait cette
décision de mettre en place des couloirs
humanitaires cette décision elle en
faisait partie donc cesser aussi
histoire de dire que la russie est hélas
encore une fois pour une opération
humanitaire et c'est comme ça d'ailleurs
que la russie présente cette opération
qu'elle n'appelle pas guerre à
l'intérieur de ses propres frontières
mais effectivement c'est là de dire que
la russie est là pour apporter la paix
pour sauver pour sauver les gens alors
qu'en réalité c'est tout l'inversé qui
se passe c'est inimaginable bien sûr
julien theron pour les ukrainiens
d'accepter ce type de couloirs
humanitaires ah bah oui effectivement
quand votre pays est agressé et bombardé
notamment les civils par une puissance
en jalles vous allez pas vers cette
puissance pour vous réfugier à la notion
de réfugié fait fait lien avec ce qu'on
appelle la protection internationale
c'est à dire que un état ou
éventuellement l'onu mais là encore son
état se substitue à l'état qui ne peut
pas les protéger parce qu'en
l'occurrence faire la guerre donc vous
imaginez bien que vous n'allez pas
substituer à protection de votre état
qui est censé vous protégé par l'état
qui vous agressent naturellement oui oui
il ya un aspect aussi dans le dans la
théorie des conflits parce que une fois
que vous avez sorti la population une
fois que vous avez créé ces faux couloir
là vous pouvez dire eh bien nous avons
fait sortir tous les civils il reste que
les combattants et en syrie on appelait
ça les terroristes donc même cédé civile
ou et on considère que c'est quand même
des combattants et puis du coup on peut
bombarder et rasé la ville donc à même
un intérêt soul et de communication
militaire derrière je voudrais réagir si
vous me permettez à ce que disait je
viens parce que il faut aussi rappeler
qu' on ne va pas se réfugier dans
vers un état qui nous agressent mais
c'est exactement ce qu'ont fait les
populations des régions de donetsk de
lougansk parce qu'avant même la tacc de
la russie et j étais à la frontière je
voyais arriver ces réfugiés il a eu
cette opération déclaré par les
autorités séparatistes de denner et de
leener d'évacuation de ces territoires
en brandissant la menace d'une attaque
ukrainienne c'était une évacuation qui
précédait à toute escalade et ses
populations à soual et vers la russie et
ont été accueillis vers la russie et à
nos journalistes présents à la frontière
on nous disait il n'y aura que la russie
pour nous sauver parce qu'il voit
l'histoire de ce conflit complètement à
l'envers à l'envers et donc c'est de la
propagande en fait exactement on va
écouter le maire de carson une personne
c'est l'une des villes qui est tombée
aux mains des russes il a été interrogé
par notre confrère marc perelman on les
écoute
mais
je voulais rendre et justement vous qui
était à kiev et qu'ils aient résisté et
résistant le craignaient en fait
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce couloir
humanitaire proposée par les russes
jeu j'ai vu aujourd'hui c'est cool de
voir des russes que c'était moi ils
essaient de créer une image pour ses
propres habitants les habitants de la
russie pour montrer que quand on est
ouvert à la paix on porte le label
l'ukraine n'a est encore créer une image
dans le monde
pour l'europe et les états unis parce
que il me semble que la russie s'ouvre
maintenant à cause des sanctions de
sanctions donc est ce assez ses couloirs
humanitaires il me
ça c'est une une des machines des
propagandes de remise de rouvroy ouï
dire que c'est que c'est le guerre est
vraiment un
pour porter la paire une crème c'est
comme ça que l'hiver la pologne est le
principal pays d'accueil des réfugiés
pour l'instant j'ai vu qu'elle accueille
à elle seule plus de neuf cent vingt
mille à personne vous y étiez d'ailleurs
tout récemment on peut dire que les
polonais quoi font preuve d'une
solidarité exceptionnelle
je ne sais pas s'il faut en trouver le
mot exceptionnel c'est un événement
exceptionnel qui évidemment ces sites la
solidarité oui des polonais et les
autres pays limitrophes les mythos frau
limitrophes excusez-moi de l'ukraine on
a vu des stands où ils accueillent
les arrivants d'ukraine avec du thé avec
des français pour faye il ya oui aussi
des oliviers qui se sont mises en place
il me semble que les associations le
milieu associatif polonais s'est
mobilisé un peu plus rapidement que le
gouvernement après le gouvernement a
saisi que l'opinion publique était en
faveur d' accueillir
ces ukrainiens ici c'est une guerre ce
n'est pas vraiment la même chose que les
migrants qui venait qui essaient dé
traverser la biélorussie qui essayait de
passer en pologne de par cette voie là
et les polonais ont été beaucoup taxé de
racisme à cause de cela puisque
évidemment les ukrainiens sont blancs
les migrants qui essayait de traverser
par l'abbé laurie s'ils venaient du
moyen-orient d'afrique et des pays comme
ça et je pense qu évidemment il y a une
part de vérité dans cela mais il ya
aussi le fait que cette guerre est
tellement plus proche de la pologne
c'est tellement direct ils n'ont pas à
interroger si ces ukrainiens qui
viennent d'ukraine sont des migrants
plutôt économique ou si c'est vraiment
des gens qui fuient les dangers il est
absolument clair et évident pour les
polonais que ces ukrainiens sont en
danger et qu'il fuit une guerre qui
vient juste d'éclater et je pense que
oui c'est pour cela qu'il y à ce grand
contraste convoi entre l'accueil demandé
de l'accueil par don offert aux
ukrainiens par rapport au refus
d'admettre les migrants qui venait dé du
moyen-orient et d'afrique à travers la
biélorussie en fin de l'année dernière
surtout faudrait que je lis ya plus de
deux cent mille réfugiés ukrainien
d'ailleurs qui ont transité par la
moldavie ce pays tout petit pays de deux
millions et demi et d'habitants qui est
l'un des plus proches de l'un des plus
pauvres d'europe il redoute en fait une
crise humanitaire également ce pays
vous en avez entendu parler une partie
de son territoire d'ailleurs la
transnistrie et déjà contrôlé par des
séparatistes russe
we've à la situation effectivement est
dramatique pour nombre de populations
civiles ce qui lui manque aujourd'hui
c'est déjà une vision directe puisque le
cicr est en train de se redéployer
jusqu'à présent depuis 2014 nous
travaillons uniquement dans le bon basse
de miel six afghans ci avec une
représentation diplomatique à kiev et
nous étions aussi physiquement présent à
marioupol maintenant il faut pouvoir
renforcer c'est ce qui se passe
actuellement avec nombre de collègues
qui rentrent en ukraine avec pour
objectif de se déployer ailleurs
puisque maintenant le conflit s'est
élargi à l'entièreté du territoire et
donc de pouvoir apporter d'être au plus
proche des populations est en tout cas
de ce que nous savons faire et ce que
nous pouvons faire au profit des
populations mais oui les urgences
humanitaires
que ce soit en transnistrie que ce soit
à la périphérie de l'ukraine et bien
évidemment à l'intérieur de l'ukraine
sont de plus en plus prégnante et vous
souhaitez qui est des couloirs
humanitaires qui sont organisées
les couloirs dans l'histoire récente des
conflits armés ça n'a jamais vraiment
fonctionné il ya d'ailleurs peu
d'exemples dans l'histoire qui puisse
ramener que des corridors ou des
couloirs humanitaires est vraiment
remplit une fonction efficace je
rappelle quand même que le droit
international humanitaire les fameuses
conventions de genève prévoit avant tout
un accès inconditionnel aux humanitaires
aux personnes qui en ont besoin c'est à
dire essentiellement les populations
civiles et puis aussi que les
belligérants ont la responsabilité de
d'un espace humanitaire ou justement ne
se trouvent que des victimes et que des
lits sauveteurs qui l'ont santé qui sont
censés le re porter secours un corridor
humanitaire ça sent plus simple à se
représenter un point a vers un point b
mais imaginez bien que lorsque vous avez
deux cent mille personnes à marioupol
donc des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui veulent s'en aller et bien
celle qui se trouve à deux ou à trois
kilomètres du de l'hypothétique corridor
comment font-elles est-ce qu'ils doivent
quitter leurs abris pour rejoindre le
corridor est traversé par leurs propres
moyens plusieurs kilomètres dans des
conditions extrêmement précaires de
sécurité est ce qu'elles ne vont pas
s'exposer à des risques supplémentaires
que ce qu'elles subissent depuis
qu'elles sont dues depuis qu'elles sont
bunkérisé par exemple dans tant d'écart
ça montre toute la problématique de mise
en oeuvre de ce type d'opération pour
autant il faut essayer d'encourager ce
qui s'est passé à marioupol même si ça a
été un échec et coup sur coup avant
thierry hier avec ce projet où les
parties au conflit s'était entendu pour
que les civils puissent sortir ça n'a
pas fonctionné mais pour autant ça veut
quand même dire que sur la table entre
les différentes parties il était un
moment donné d'accord pour remplir un
agenda strictement humanitaires qui
visait à faire sortir
les populations tout ce qui peut
contribuer à soulager la souffrance
actuelle des populations est bon à
prendre mais il faut véritablement que
ceux ci soient dénués de tout autre
agenda que strictement humanitaires et
la voulait réagir je voudrais juste dire
c'est terrible à dire est terrible à
admettre mais le fait que ces corridors
humanitaires ne marche pas c'est aussi
parce que les deux parties
instrumentalise le fait que l'autre
partie serait en train d'attaquer les
civils qui essayent de s'évacuer alors
qu'il ya des provocations et que souvent
on tire sur le corridor humanitaire pour
ensuite dire que l'autre partie est
attaqué c'est ce que font beaucoup je
parle pour les russes parce que je
regarde les chaînes de télévision russes
par exemple qui attire qui accuse
toujours les ukrainiens de prendre les
civils pour boucliers humains c'est mais
je sais en pratique que healy à cette
pratique côté russe en tout cas de
procéder à ces provocations pour
empêcher les ukrainiens de sortir et
ensuite accusé l'armée ukrainienne de
mettre à mal ses corridors humanitaires
donc attention juliette héros serait
qu'on peut pas on peut plus s'empêcher
de penser à alep à la syrie quand on
voit ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en ce
12e jour de conflit
on a l'impression que c'est une guerre
totale on parle effectivement maintenant
de couloirs humanitaires de réfugiés
dont quel côté militaire le côté cyber
le côté guerre informationnelle ça veut
dire c'est une guerre qui a priori sera
de longue durée alors juste sur le terme
de guerre totale dans science politique
c'est pas ce qu'on appelle une guerre
totale c'est pas exactement le terme je
sais que c'est très courant aujourd'hui
et ça mais c'est ça qu'est ce qui manque
pour que ce soit une guerre totale c'est
l'absolue intégralité de la population
et de l'état ni aux services de chefs
militaires ce qui n'est pas le cas ni en
russie c'est plus le cas déjà en ukraine
dans une stratégie de résistance mais
qu'était conceptualiser dans une loi de
résistance nationale début janvier mais
on voulait qualifier alors cette guerre
aujourd'hui
en science politique on appelle ça une
guerre conventionnelle
c'est c'est en fait assez classique du
point de vue militaire sauf que du point
de vue craignent un il ya la
mobilisation de l'ensemble de l'appareil
de l'état et aussi de la population dans
un effort commun de résistance pour les
termes techniques s'appelle role of
government are all of society mais voilà
c'est un petit peu c'est un petit peu
technique mais en revanche ça ne veut
pas dire que c'est une question
d'intensité il y a une intensité très
forte qui est en train de monter c'est
juste une question de qualification de
plus du point de vue du droit
international je voudrais renforcer même
ce qui a été dit du point de vue du cicr
non seulement le couloir humanitaire ça
ne fonctionne pas bien on a vu par
exemple à vous parler de la syrie
stéphanie il y avait des couloirs
humanitaires aussi appelé comme ça en
syrie au bout duquel les services de
renseignements syriens attendaient les
civils pour les trier souvent est ce que
je veux dire et savoir un petit peu
qu'ils pouvaient interrogé avec une
pratique très traditionnel de la torture
donc effectivement
c'est s était pas vraiment très
humanitaires comme on peut dire et de
toute façon et c'est le point que je
veux renforcer avec le délégué du cicr
mais
il il est interdit en droit national de
bombarder les civils de toute façon on
n'a pas le droit dassier j'ai une ville
avec des civils à l'intérieur on n'a pas
le droit de bombarder un hôpital on n'a
pas droit de bombarder un marché on n'a
pas le droit de cibler les civils
on n'a même pas le droit d'utiliser des
armes qu'on appelle non discriminante
c'est à dire qu'il ne ferait pas la
différence entre un combattant et un non
combattants et quand je dis non
combattants s'est même pas que les
civils c'est aussi les militaires
blessés normand n'a pas le droit de
faire ça on n'a pas le droit d'user des
mines personnel n'a pas le droit d'user
dé des munitions à sous munitions donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que on en
arrive à se dire bon bah ils sont quand
même sympa de faire des couloirs
humanitaires dont elena nous expliquer
un peu la réalité mais en réalité on en
arrive à à penser ça au bout d'une série
de pratiques qui ne conviennent pas du
tout dans les lois de la guerre et oui
la guerre à des lois lors du point de
vue de la doctrine russes ont dit il
mais dans la guerre c'est normal il ya
des morts et à des civils qui sont tués
c'est pareil partout non les pratiques
militaires
et en fonction des états c'est ce qu'on
appelle les crimes de guerre ça peut
être qualifiée des crimes de guerre ce
n'est pas à moi de le dire ça la jeune
star nationale amnistie internationale
justin ont justement tellement bien
qu'elle lui le chef de diplomatie
américaine dit qu'il a des informations
très crédibles sur des crimes de guerre
commis par la russie ont l'écoutent
nous avons assisté à une mobilisation
planétaire contre l'agression russe
contre cette guerre choisie par la
russie
à la suite de plusieurs jours de
réunions avec le temps l'union
européenne des pays au delà du g7 nous
constatons que le soutien l'ukraine va
se poursuivre un soutien pour sa
sécurité un soutien humanitaire et
économique qui va s'amplifier
oui l'hiver la cour pénale
internationale puisqu'on en parle et a
ouvert une enquête sur la situation en
ukraine selon le procureur de la cour
pénale il existe une base raisonnable
pour croire que des crimes relevant de
la compétence de la cour ont été commis
les ukrainiens y tiennent me semble-t-il
oui je pense que les ukrainiens tiennent
absolument à ce que
la russie soit condamné à la et il
voudrait voir les dirigeants russes puni
pour ce qu'ils font et je pense que
toute initiative en ce sens et bienvenue
les ukrainiens en ce moment regarde
vraiment vers l'ouest vers la communauté
internationale et demande une réponse
une réponse plus forte plus dead surtout
comme le président l'a souligné maintes
fois il voudrait zone d'interdiction de
voler au dessus de l'ukraine afin que
que l'otan appliquerait ça c'est la
demande qui est entendu tous les jours
l'annnonce de boris johnson de son point
clancy point qui paraît assez ridicule
complètement vague n'est pas passé
inaperçu en ukraine ça a été reçue comme
comme come in sync est en fait laurent
sommes unis et les autres pays de
l'occident allait finir par abandonner
malgré tout ce que anthony blinken
décrivez là sur la mobilisation
internationale pour condamner la russie
pour ce qu'elle fait malgré tout ces
sanctions sont précédentes qui ont été
appliqués vue d'ukraine ça reste pas
assez il ya encore cette peur que
finalement ça ne l'ouest ne sera pas à
la hauteur et que finalement l'ukraine
va devoir se
sauver tout seul je l'interromps
justement sur cette zone d'exclusion
aérienne c'est vraiment la ligne rouge
que ne veulent pas franchir les
occidentaux oui très clairement en fait
techniquement stricto sensu il n'est pas
obligé d'avoir des accrochages entre
députés hâtive troupe du creux otanienne
qui conserverait la maîtrise du ciel et
les russes mais c'est quand même
extrêmement risquée qui est un
accrochage et est très clairement l'otan
ne veut pas franchir ce pas
du point de vue craignent un on peut
quand même considérer qu'il ya un effort
de l'ouest envers l'ukraine avec des
livraisons d'armes technologique anti
tank et un anti aériennes ce qui n'était
pas le cas en syrie par exemple les
occidentaux n'ont jamais voulu le faire
ce qui fait que les syriens n'ont pas pu
en fait combattre donc malgré les
encouragements à résister naturellement
ils n'ont pas pu le faire et puis à
cette affaire aussi des avions de combat
vous savez alors l'otan avait annoncé en
soutien
2 les occidentaux un soutien à la
livraison d'anciens appareils soviétique
ça prend du temps à former sur d'autres
appareils et le secrétaire blinken a
justement engager un dialogue avec les
polonais pour qu'ils livrent leurs
anciennes armes soviétiques aux
ukrainiens qui savent les piloter et
qu'il les remplacerait par des f 16 dont
il ya quand même un effort otaniens en
soutien mais il est vrai que
il se passe un phénomène très fin et
c'est très important de le comprendre et
qui qui est très très rarement dit c'est
que il ya ce qu'on appelle la fatigue de
guerre ça existe pour les combattants
c'est à dire les troupes combattantes
qui au bout d'un moment en ont marre de
faire la guerre parce que c'est très
éprouvant mais ça existe aussi pour les
sociétés alors aujourd'hui on est dans
un temps de l'émotion on accueille les
réfugiés il ya un million cinq ou sept
cent mille d'après ce que je comprends
aujourd'hui qui qui se réfugier mais il
ya 44 millions d'ukrainiens donc
imaginer qu'ils aient 20 millions
d'ukrainiens qui viennent se réfugier en
europe les populations locales vont être
commencer à dire quelque chose puis à la
fatigue médiatique aussi de traiter un
sujet on le voit il ya une vraie demande
de la population d'information est à la
fois au bout d'un moment les gens c'est
assez je pense que vous connaissez ce
genre de choses quelque chose d'assez
rationnelle les gens ont envie de passer
à autre chose donc ce que je veux dire
c'est que les populations aujourd'hui
européennes sont en soutien de la cause
ukrainienne mais il y a un risque
effectivement que la tension retombe que
le soutien retombe que la mobilisation
retombées que les gouvernements eux
mêmes
mme hollis un petit peu qu'ils aient
d'autres choses qui se passent voire
même que la russie joue là dessus en
créant des contre-feux alors on a vu
déjà apparaître violation du territoire
aérien sur l'île de suédoise de gotland
on parle de la bosnie herzégovine avec
cette partie celle qui veut c'est pas
rien faire je dire ils peuvent créer
d'autres contre-feu voir avoir des
pratiques en ukraine même des pratiques
militaires voire contraire au droit
international qui choque les occidentaux
qui nous font peur c'est ce qu'ils
essaient aussi de faire avec les menaces
nucléaires ce que je veux dire dans tout
ça c'est que qu avec l objet qu il ya un
risque que les soutiens de l'ukraine
faiblissent et c'est considérable à la
fois pour les ukrainiens mais aussi pour
les occidentaux que ce soutien ne
faiblissent pas c'est fondamental pour
qu'ils gagnent la guerre l'idée n'est
pas de les soutenir de soutenir les
réfugiés comme ça vitam aeternam aixois
une guerre longue six lits à soutien
c'est pour un soutien pour qu'il gagne
cette guerre et non une peuvent
effectivement gagné la guerre les
ukrainiens à l'envi damman le discours
où c'est très différent ce qui sera
intéressant d'ailleurs c'est de parler
aussi de cette population russe qui sait
y en a un certain nombre qui ont
manifesté qui sont contre qui sont
opposés à cette guerre qu'est ce qui
représente elena vous vous en connaissez
un certain nombre c'est de plus en plus
risqué pour eux aujourd'hui ils risquent
jusqu'à 15 ans de prison c'est ça oui il
faut comprendre il ya eu quelques
rumeurs sur l'instauration d'une loi
martiale en russie cela n'a pas encore
été fait mais de ce que j'observe de
facto il y a un semblant de loi martiale
qui existent déjà ils ont interdit tous
les médias indépendants quand vous
voulez ouvrir un site d'information en
russe pour vous informer ce n'est plus
possible il n'ya plus de sites il ya une
loi qui interdit d'appeler la guerre la
guerre il a une loi qui interdit de
discréditer les actions de paix de
l'armée russe enfin on est en train de
construire une contre vérité absolue on
voit que la violence des arrestations
qui a qui a eu lieu pendant ces
dernières manifestations où certains ou
le courage de braver l'interdiction et
d'aller manifester leur soutien à
l'ukraine c'est sans précédent on peut
aussi craindre qu'il y aura des
représailles a posteriori le parquet
général menace les russes qui
travaillent pour des organisations
étrangères de trahison d'état on voit
apparaître des mots comme extrémisme
pour qualifier ce que font les médias
c'est ce qu'on ne voyait pas avant on
voyait cela et encore c'était déjà grave
pour les pour les opposants mais on est
dans une situation de répression
montante sans précédent quasiment de
dictature de guerre en qui est en train
de s'installer en russie et je vois mal
comment dans cette situation alors que
vladimir poutine l'a est décidé à
imposer sa volonté par la force et non
par l'adhésion je vois mal comment dans
cette situation là il pourra y avoir des
gens qui vont continuer à sortir
manifester pour leur soutien à l'ukraine
sachant déjà que y sont largement
minoritaires ceux qui osent braver les
interdits du livet à ce que vous êtes
d'accord à ce que vient de dire julien
theron est ce qu effectivement il ya un
moment où les ukrainiens vont avoir peur
qu'on les soutienne plus parce qu'il y
aura cette fatigue qui viens d'évoquer
oui c'est ce qui est sûr c'est que cette
peur existe déjà on entend de temps en
temps les ukrainiens dire que oui au
bout d'un moment vous pourrez peut-être
même autour de moi je ne sais pas si
vous voyez sur cette place moment où on
a commencé ce débat je voyais trois
autres correspondants installé sur la
place centrale de lviv qui faisait des
directs il y à une attention médiatique
très intense en ce moment sur ce qui se
passe au nul en ukraine qui ne peut pas
être maintenu
indéfiniment donc forcément il y aura
une certaine best de l'intensité de la
couverture dans les médias et les
ukrainiens craignent que cela pourrait
aussi engendrer une affaiblissement de
la mobilisation des gouvernements des
pays alliés de l'ukraine en soutien de
ces pays et contre contre la russie
c'est certainement une crainte qui
existe est ce que elle se réalisera je
ne m'aventurerai pas à le prédire parce
que je trouve tout de même que cette
guerre est exceptionnel c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas vu en europe depuis
1945 c'est vraiment qualitativement
quelque chose de différent tu que les
autres guerres qu'on a vu que les autres
événements traumatisants très médiatisé
pendant quelques semaines et ensuite non
alors l'avenir l'avenir nous montrera
qu'est ce qu'il en sera on va écouter
justement je le disais il ya quelques
instants le maire de kherson une ville
donc qui est tombée aux mains des russes
au micro donc de marc perelman on écoute
ici il n'y a pas d'amélioration en ce
qui concerne l'aide humanitaire j'ai
peur que la situation s'aggrave de
manière très significative et c'est
probable que les gens et fin
andré vous qui êtes justement à kiev et
qui résistaient justement quand vous
entendez le maire de kherson quelle est
votre réaction
ma réaction donc j'ai vraiment
très très choqué des gens
qui n'ont pas beaucoup de nourriture
mais qui refuse d
des produits qui étaient apportées par
les russes sur les cammazes blanc à il a
vécu ça il montre sa résistance et il le
montre régime de poutine qu'ils ne
veulent pas avoir les russies ici
il montre sa force intérieure on dit
chez nous et je pense que ne le
gouvernement crée bien bas on va trouver
la solution pour donner la nourriture
eau
aux halles et parents de personnes
aimées nord moi je voudrais juste
revenir un petit peu en arrière cette
question de gagner ou perdre la guerre
parce que pourquoi est-ce que l'ukraine
se voit attaquer aujourd'hui et
l'ukraine dans cette situation
désastreuse c'est parce que depuis le
début elle n'a pas réussi à avoir un
vrai soutien par rapport à la guerre qui
avait déjà lieu sur son territoire par
rapport à cette guerre en ukraine de
l'est très localisées qui n'intéressait
personne et le fait est que pourquoi
elle n'a pas réussi à voir ce soutien
parce que la russie a réussi aussi à
convertir les opinions publiques
occidentales à sa version qui était que
finalement non elle n'avait pas envahi
l'ukraine elle n'était pas partie
prenante de ce conflit c'était une
guerre civile etc et qui a réussi à
écrire cette contre vérité or
aujourd'hui il ya une certaine cohésion
des opinions publiques occidentales face
à l'ampleur de l'agression russe est à
l'évidence de la situation on voit enfin
que oui la russie est en train
d'agresser le pays voisin mais moi ce
que je crains c'est que dans les
prochaines semaines et dans les
prochains mois il y a de nouveau une
opération de propagande à destination d
opinion publique occidentale de la
russie et on voit déjà apparaître des
sites en anglais en français en espagnol
qui luttent soi-disant contre les fake
des médias occidentaux qui dénoncent
cette guerre et qui parlent de cette
guerre on voit déjà apparaître cela et
je ne serais pas étonné que l'opinion
publique occidentale
ne voit plus dans un certain temps
l'agression de la russie contre
l'ukraine qui est évidente aujourd'hui
mais que la vérité recommencent à se
perdre dans un dans un flou
informationnelle et de propagande qui va
se mélanger et on ne verra plus on va
plus pouvoir démêler le vrai du faux
donc elle pourrait gagner la guerre
informationnelle c'est très important
mois au cours de toutes ces années ça
fait dix ans que je suis basé en russie
au cours de toutes ces années y compris
les propagandistes de la télévision
russe me disait on ne gagne pas la
guerre si on ne gagne pas la guerre de
l'information générale pourrait vous
êtes d'accord il y admirer la machine
complètement il ya l'aspect militaire
mais il y a
aujourd'hui on gagne une guerre
politique non en fait et évidemment
l'information en fait partie de manière
considérable la syrie au début tout le
monde le soutenait il ya une résolution
qui équivalent est quasiment au début de
la guerre en syrie pardon de la guerre
de la révolution syrienne précisément
qui n'était pas une guerre au début il
ya une résolution quasiment aussi
unanime de l'assemblée générale sur la
syrie que celle qui vient d'avoir / / /
l'ukraine c'est une résolution de
l'assemblée générale elle n'est pas
comment dire elle n'est pas
obligé d'être d'être suivie comme celle
selon le chapitre 7 e d'aidés du conseil
de sécurité mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que ça n'a rien changé
la complexification de la guerre le
pourrissement de la guerre et la
propagande ont fait qu'au bout d'un
moment
les opinions publiques ont dit oui mais
il ya quand même des terroristes oui
mais on sait pas ce qui s'y passe parce
qu'on empêchait l'accès aux situations
sur sur le terrain j'en avais parlé avec
des gens de l' agence de presse qui
m'expliquait toutes les méthodes qui
avait pour empêcher les journalistes les
chercheurs les humanitaires d'accéder
aux situations dans ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il ya de multiples levier comme
ça qui permettent de gagner une guerre
politiquement et e
encore une fois je le précise la raison
pour laquelle la russie l'iran et le
régime de bachar al assad ont maintenu
la situation en syrie c'est parce qu'ils
ont tenue dans le temps et que nous nous
avons évanouie notre soutien aux
démocrates syriens qu'on a qu'on avait
en 2011 et là j'ose espérer que les
occidentaux ont bien compris que c'était
une affaire extrêmement importante et ce
sont un petit peu réveillé mais cette
tenue dans le temps et considérablement
importante on va écouter jean yves le
drian le chef de la diplomatie française
qui s'est exprimé aujourd'hui sur
justement cette aide humanitaire de 500
millions d'euros qui a été annoncé par
l'union européenne on écoute
nous avons sur les sièges initié par
les forces armées russes
une sinistre expertise
dans la dernière manifestation récente
était celle d'alec
avec sans arrêt le même scénario
bombardements
proposition de corridors sanitaire
humanitaire
dénonciation de la rupture du corridor
par l'adversaire
tentative de
négociation et pour parler pour mieux
condamner l'adversaire qui sort de ces
négociations parce qu'on le pourra pas
qu'à sortir
rebond barre de man et on recommence
enfin dès que je lis justement vous
feriez un parallèle entre ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en ukraine ce qui
s'est passé en série comme le fait le
chef de la diplomatie française
je crois que malheureusement chaque
conflit et sa dynamique propre on peut
faire des points de comparaison pour
revenir à la représentation de ce qu'est
la vie t'en guerre et que en aucune
façon la population peut être peut-être
à un enjeu c'est pas l'humanitaire qui
va régler le conflit actuel en ukraine
c'est bien la politique et c'est bien à
travers des négociations entre les
différentes parties et plus largement
avec la communauté internationale que se
trouveront les solutions pour aider la
population ukrainienne en attendant val
humanitaire fait ce qu'il peut alors
bien évidemment le cicr en tant
qu'intermédiaire neutre et puis gardien
du fameux droit international
humanitaire des fameuses conventions de
genève et c'est aussi la mobilisation
des volontaires de la croix-rouge
ukrainienne et puis c'est aussi la
mobilisation internationale de
l'initiative privée que l'on retrouve à
travers les ong et bien évidemment
l'entièreté du mouvement international
de la croix rouge que ce soit la croix
rouge française que ce soit la croix
rouge allemande évidemment polonaise
évidemment molleda mais aussi russes
bref cette mobilisation pour essayer de
de soulager la souffrance des
populations ukrainienne mais c'est
véritablement le champ de la politique
qui pourra régler le problème quand
comme dans toutes les situations de
conflit armé à lui de confirmer mais en
attendant il est important aussi de
rappeler que tous les états les 187
états parties aux conventions de genève
se sont engagés à respecter et à faire
respecter en toutes circonstances le
droit international humanitaire et même
si ça peut apparaître comme une utopie
c'est quelque chose qui est partagée par
la communauté internationale et que
cette boussole ne doit jamais être perdu
dans quelle que soit la situation de
conflit armé que l'on est amené à
traverser merci beaucoup et léna
peut-être un mot de conclusion rapide
dans le monde
en tout cas voilà sur les négociations
qui peut-être reprendre à un moment
donné en tout cas sur le front
diplomatique
moi je vois mal comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait sortir d'une situation vladimir
poutine tout ce qu'il n'obtiendra pas
verra comme une montée de la
confrontation et la nécessité d'obtenir
ce qu'il veut par les armes or là
clairement ses exigences vis-à-vis de
l'otan sont irrecevables et dans ce
contexte là même le fait que le temps
renforce ses troupes en roumanie par
exemple peut être perçue par le dit mr
poutine comme un signe supplémentaire
qu'il doit maintenir le bras de fer est
temps qu'on ne va pas au compromis avec
des exigences irrecevable la situation
est sans issue merci beaucoup et les
nanas volochine merci julien theron
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous
frédéric joly merci gulliver a vu
l'hiver prague qui étaient avec nous à
vif et puis et merci à vous andré vous
étiez avec nous à kiev merci à vous tous
nous avons suivi reste avec moi sur
france 24
[Musique]